[Applause]
look at my beautiful
Brothers the voners are the greatest
family in the history of wrest I'm going
to flex for a little bit Chris Jericho
famous wrestler is one of my good
friends and he's talked to me about how
you have to Hype yourself before you go
in the ring and I'm wondering for you
guys as performers before you went into
the ring to perform those scenes if
there was a hype moment for sure I mean
like Zach was the hype man I me he's
hype man number one he really you mean
the character or Zach
Z was so supportive I think yeah yeah
acoss the route it was really fun and
rewarding to work with these guys
they're they're hungry and like clearly
devoted um and it was just evident every
day sometimes halfway through the day
we' have finished you know two or three
matches and they were still wanting to
work on the moves and get things right
and just committed to to trying new
things and like a lot of it hurt you
know it it added up yeah but um so it it
was just I was blown away that every day
we were still elevating pushing each
other and there for one another and you
know pumping each other up before takes
and stuff like that it really felt like
we were creating this brother
Brotherhood Dynamic it was really
special yeah before those like wrestling
scenes a lot of us yeah trying to like I
think like listen to the music and
feeling the the the audience and
definitely yeah like just crowd
definitely helped and so the crowd was
allowed to make noise cuz sometimes you
can't most they they're silent going it
doesn't help it's different when you
when the whole crowd's out there and you
hear the rumble of their
feet they really gave it like every time
as did you ever get lost in sort of that
and go oh my God I can't believe what I
just like I just kind of like did more
than I thought I was going to do in in
the moment yeah was that was so night
like we were doing these like really
long takes these sequences from getting
to end and had the crowd going and it
was just us and the camera would often
be kind of like in the crowd so so it's
very easy to kind of like separate from
from the film and kind of like get lost
in those those moments I think
specifically in those kind of like
wrestling sequences yeah Harris David is
I feel like he was the biggest showman
of the group The Greatest showman of the
group and he doing those wrestling
promos very un English because English
tends to be a little bit more quiet
self-deprecating but I also understood
that you had the most fun with the
costuming in wardrobe and yours was sort
of the most out there so if he's could
maybe talk as a performer about
performing those scenes where you're
doing those big promos and that kind of
thing yeah they were really fun I feel
like David when we sort of dove into his
costume it was clear that in real life
he had a real like he had a flare and he
wasn't afraid to like you know wear his
cowboy hat and he was he was a true
Texas boy you know he enjoyed it and and
the costumes were amazing like J our
costume designer she really stayed true
to a lot of the actual like um outfits
that the boys wore so it was it was
really fun I mean the yellow I had a
yellow pair of hot pants that said um
the the yellow Rose of Texas on them on
on the bum so that was
fun felt like a love letter to Texas
yeah you know Texas is a real big
character yeah 100% yeah just in general
I truly believed you were all Brothers
down to the fact that even though none
of you really look alike the
mannerisms everything about you guys I'm
wondering if you did do any sort of
preparation or if that was a direction
that maybe Shawn gave you who works with
the voice coach yeah there was a voice
coach we were all working with um I
think was that was really helpful and
then and then obviously like the
physicality and stuff like I don't know
what what came from kind of like just
naturally comes from kind of like
watching and like mimicking and kind of
like finding that that that thing but
but also yeah we we were training so
much uh in the ring together that wasn't
necessarily like rehearsal work for for
some of the other things but but yeah I
guess we were we were kind of like
picking up on on each other's movement
and voice also like placed Us in the
world that he was we all felt like we
were in the same film like sha did a
really good job at like Sean is a master
of that we all felt uh that the tone of
the film he really kept track of which
is so challenging to do and um there was
also a sense I think for all of us
individually as people and as actors
that we were going through a very shared
experience and that just makes a bond I
don't know how else to put it for you I
know that you met Kevin after filming
you met him around the time of the
premiere in Dallas
but I'm wondering for you as an actor
you've already played this character but
then when you get to meet him what
specifically about that meeting did you
go oh I got that right like I'm so glad
that I kind of instinctually played it
that way and what came across you about
that meeting first of all it's it was
interesting because I didn't get to meet
over over the course of filming but of
course his his take on the movie was
something I was considering the whole
time that was one of the major
motivating forces just to push and to
stay in the gym and to you know keep
perfecting all these moves and and to
elevate through every jump and to get it
right you know knowing that Kevin was
was uh really going to see this and and
uh that that was hugely motivating but
when we got to speak after uh filming
was complete it was so special to hear I
think what he took away most from it was
how the bond and the brother
relationship of it all that meant the
world to him I mean that was that was
everything that's something that maybe
we couldn't really even feel it at the
time there was there was some real magic
in there that that he felt and that is
was my biggest takeaway there was even
magic like when I saw the truck scene
and you're the way you're eating burgers
I'm like that's how brothers would
really eat burgers together no females
around not trying to impress anybody
Stanley for you your P tril like I know
that you've all said in the previous
interview that the most fun you probably
had on set was the party scene and you
got to perform live in front of that
group can you kind of talk about that um
just sort of belting it out I know you
sang A High School Musical song and I
want to know what song that that was
yeah it was a Breaking Free Breaking
Free um Sean was just like let's have
like a party like let's have a real
party and dude jumping off a roof into a
pool and it follows you know Jeremy like
holding the drinks into the to to the to
that little show section where I'm
playing and you know we played it live
and I had a really good group around me
they're their b a real band uh they're
called uh lovers and um yeah we just we
just had fun
amazing yeah party scenes can be kind of
laborious to film everyone's got to keep
their energy up but this one was just a
blast yeah I was Fring playing liveb but
then as soon as we started it was so
much
fun